why would it be that a guy who creates
such destruction who ruined So Many
Lives who seems so deeply inauthentic I
mean if you thought Trump was smug if
that's what they thought about Trump
that Trump is smug this guy is the
smuggiest in smugtown okay but why would
certain amount of people be Bamboozled
by this sort of thing well it's because
a certain amount of people are NPCs
these are non-playable characters who
can't think for themselves so they watch
The View we need somebody who can get
the country back on on line in line yeah
because it's you know it it if you can
name me a republican who has a shot yeah
to do that that's what I'm more
interested in because I think it'll
death Santa I hope it's not dead fantas
over in Florida because I think he's a
fashionable Santa's I think I think he
handled covet miserably I think he's a
fascist and a bigot but I uh those are
his good points those are his good
points exactly
but but I do think there plenty of you
know Democrats that have tons of Verve
and energy I mean I like Gavin Newsom
because he's really pretty to look at
and I think he does a great job in
California
um I like Kamala Kamala and Pete budaja
I love tickets I think that looks great
do you think they could win really well
I would vote for them I hope this
country is ready for something like that
I think the brain power alone would
would just obliterate Trump or and I
would just love to
how many of you just barfed
kind of read a little little vomit that
he just swallowed down even though we've
shown you that clip before and we played
it for ourselves right before the show
as we did our run through that woman is
so unbearable but I don't want to make
this about Sunny house and I want to
make this about the ideas that she's
talking about there first off you just
call him death sentence you just call
him the guy who kept the state open the
guy who has the second oldest population
in the United States I don't know if you
know this if you ever saw the Golden
Girls a lot of old people in Florida and
their rates of covet and death and
everything else were basically on par
with California he fought to make sure
people could go to work and not ruin
kids lives and everything else I can
tell you in case you don't know it you
all know how much I love Florida
everywhere I go here there is such
appreciation for this guy there is such
a zest for life here it is the fact that
I'm going to LA today it's kind of funny
but this is the show we're doing today
I'm going back to Cali to LA tonight and
I just know I just know for all the joy
that you see in people's faces here uh
that it doesn't exist there because I
went back a couple months ago and it was
a nightmare this utopian awfulness whose
idea was this trip
was your idea anyway
um so okay he's and then she you know
casually he's death saying this he's a
fascist and a bigot yes he's a fascist
he wants to use State and corporate
power together to stop people that's
literally what the Democrats were doing
with kovid right you were literally
trying to join have the federal
government Force companies to inject
their people with a experimental drug
that is that the most fascistic thing
that I can think of that is uh Philip K
dick level sci-fi fascism okay uh and
he's a bigot I mean it's just these
things are meaningless they are
absolutely meaningless he is not a bigot
he is not a homophobe or anything else
you may not like him because you don't
like functioning people who care about
America and care about Freedom what is
she like well Gavin newsom's very
handsome he's not handsome he's gross I
cannot imagine much more grow he's gross
he's absolutely disgusting